alright it is time for hatred mail very
very special hatred mail today you'll
see why in a moment
we're so all right it's wrong Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom yes so this week's hatred mail
combines a number of elements common to
hatred mail obviously the requisite bad
syntax and grammar is there no questions
about that but we also have
anti-semitism conspiracy theories and
sort of unhinged apoplectic defenses of
Donald Trump it's all there this week
Pakman you are the biggest [ __ ] on
YouTube
that's right little Pakman that's what
you do when you were in charge you make
real man decisions who said months ago
the FBI was a piece of [ __ ] Trump he was
right again fact David Pakman is hiding
Jew gold brought to Argentina by Hitler
after he fled Germany at the end of ww2
yeah combining both Hitler didn't
actually die conspiracy theories with
Jew gold conspiracy theories which we've
actually heard before on the program you
should at least share the Jew gold I
know right it's so selfish of me to hide
all of Hitler's gold in Argentina or
whatever it is it says if you want to
send a middle finger to the hatred so
you can use the membership coupon code
hatred for th8 ER io t it'll save you
40% and 3 hey tree it's cry every time
you use that coupon code on our website